All right, here we go. All right, today's Zoom call we're going to talk about keeping the gut healthy, keeping your gut healthy.
And again, when we talk to cancer patients about gut health and you have breast cancer, you go, what in the world do I need to do about gut health?
I have breast cancer, prostate cancer.
But it is very important because it is really the beginning of all problems is our gut.
One could argue if you wanted to argue, I would argue the cause that the majority of our health problems begin with the gut.
Because our gut inside our gut everything that you eat that goes through you is still outside of the body.
If you can think of it that way, it hasn't crossed the gut barrier to get inside your bloodstream.
It is a tube within your body. So everything is going with this tube. It's still on the outside of your body.
So the health of that gut barrier, we talk about that gut barrier, it is these little individual cells, these little parasites that create this barrier that allow things to get through that are supposed to get through.
And if that barrier is damaged and allows things to get through that aren't supposed to get through.
And that ends up causing an antigen immune reaction and causes antibodies to be created against food particles, against chemicals that it should ever have been created antibodies.
And that could just cause major problems and major inflammation.
That's where we get inflammation with the gut inflammation of the body, inflammation of the brain, and it just becomes this horrible negative cycle that could cause a lot of problems.
It can actually lead to cancer. This can actually be a cause of cancer and all sorts of different diseases because it causes basically systemic inflammation.
So these commensial bacteria react with butarate that actually help create butarate in order to feed the intestinal cells.
Butarate is the main food of your intestinal cells in order for them to be fed and nourished and to stay healthy.
So this discussion, we're just going to concentrate on butarate. Butarate is also called butaric acid.
It is formed through ingestible dietary fiber. That's why we put a lot of people had some fiber or some spectrum.
The fiber in some spectrum and some fiber is the number one studied fiber on the market.
There are more research articles on the fiber that's in that product that anything that exists on the market as far as fiber goes.
And it's the best fiber to make the most muterate. That's why we use it.
It prevents in the gut creates butarate feeds your gut cells, decreases your risk and growth of colon cancer because you have a healthier gut.
But also decreases the risk of all cancers because inflammation of the gut is going to equal inflammation of the body, the brain, and that can lead to cancer.
Increases mucus production, a good mucus layer in the gut to help protect the gut against poisons, chemicals, additives, colorades, everything that's in processed foods that you're eating.
And decreases intestinal cell permeability. So that permeability, that lack of permeability is what we want when we have an increased permeability, that's what's called leaky gut syndrome.
And that's what allows things to pass through that gut wall that were never supposed to pass through the gut wall.
So we want to promote these what are called tight junctions, the tight junctions keeps those gut cells tight together, keeps the gut cells healthy, undamaged, and doesn't allow things to get through that weren't supposed to get through.
Decreases lubanol pH. So we want that pH of the luban that attested a luban to be lower, maybe more acidic.
And to stay that way to help continue the digestive process, regulates T-reg cells, T-reg cells are your, maybe your, the cells that will cold down and immune response.
So when I have a hyperdabute response, reacting to a food or something in my gut, I want that to cold down.
Buterate helps cold down T-reg cells and modulates that immune response.
We don't want that hyperabute response inside the luban of the gut, because that's what's going to cause problems.
Buterate itself has all sorts of good anti-cancer tuber suppression effects to it.
So that's why typically we put almost every cancer patient on that fiber to help stimulate natural buterate production.
Now, we do have buterate products now that you could take buterate itself directly.
That's a product called buterate and also in terabyte, which is buterate is from allergy research product.
Anderate terabyte is a apex energetic product, which is a good source of buterate just just to help this production.
So it's a huge tumor suppressor in itself and it's a, it's a great way to, to help decrease gut inflammation and increase overall health and really decrease overall inflammation in the whole body.
Now, how do I know if I have leaky gut? How do I know what are some tests that I would do to that would suggest that I have leaky gut?
Well, first of all, besides before I get to the test, we could assume if I have any ill health problems that I have leaky gut.
So the tests that we're going to talk about are some of the Syrex tests. This is a Syrex array four.
That's as similar to the array 10, which measures many more things that this array four measures.
I think the array four has just this one sheet. The array 10 measures about six or seven sheets like this about 300 different foods.
And this is how you can, if you want some evidence of leaky gut and evidence of your leaky gut being healed, these are the kind of tests that you could run.
But we'll run these on a lot of people because you could just make an assumption that you do and it's making an assumption that you always need to work on your gut.
And that's a very safe assumption.
Now, people that want more evidence, we can certainly run these tests. These are blood tests, measured antibodies, two different food particles.
Again, our gut health here, back to this slide right here, should not let large food product particles in.
And therefore, you should have developed antibodies to these food particles.
But what our gut is damaged and we have increased permeability, meaning leaky gut here.
So it's letting large food particles in. We'll start creating antibodies to different foods.
And you have a test that looks like this. All of these should be in the green.
Now, I have run tests on people and these are all in the green, all of them, which is a great test.
Then you have to measure some other things to see, you know, other damage that might be taking place.
So that's these kind of arrays here that we'll get to in a few minutes.
But usually if a person has ill health, they're going to have a test that looks something like this.
Oh, this is actually pre-horrible. This is the worst side of a person's ill health, where this is way out of range in the red here.
Equivical is still out of range, but in the hippie side, green is in normal rage.
Now, you see they have way more, maybe three times as many that are out of rage that are in rage, which this test suggests.
This person should they stay off of the millet, should they stay off of rice and corn and buckwheat and hemp and sesame and emerald.
The answer is yes.
For just staying off these foods is not going to fix the person's problem.
When we have a test, when they're all green and there's just a couple of yellows, then the answer is yeah, if you just stay off those foods and continue what you're doing,
they're probably, that person is probably already doing a lot of gut healing.
If they just started staying off those extra little things that are causing inflammation, then their problem would be diminished.
That's an easy one to go over with a person.
But what a person has, all these reds like this, then it's like oh my gosh, you've just completely destroyed this person's life because now they can eat almost nothing.
And that becomes a little problematic and people start throwing tomatoes and stuff like that at the end.
It doesn't, it's not real great.
So really the treatment for somebody who's got a lot on a rage here is you really have to concentrate really heavily on a gut healing protocol.
That's the way that I've done it for years.
You really hit them hard on a gut healing protocol.
Have them stay away from as many of the red things as they possibly kid.
Don't worry about the yellows to begin with.
Stay off as many of these things as they can.
Get out of good gut healing program and see how their symptoms diminish.
Then there's two ways to follow up with the person.
In three months, you can run this test again.
Once you will see if they stay out of the gut healing protocol, some of these will be slid to the yellow, some of the yellows will be slid to the green.
If they did it, if you just stayed off the ones on the red and you didn't do anything for gut healing, quite possibly some of the greens could slide to yellow, some of the yellows could slide to reds, you could get worse.
You have to fix the problem.
You have to go back to this and understand that you have these permeability issues in your gut that have to be corrected.
Just stay off the food is not going to solve the problem.
Stay off the food is going to decrease the source of inflammation.
So in a way, it's going to help, but you have to heal those holes.
You have to patch up the holes of the dike or as soon as water comes down, it's going to leak right through again.
So this is an example, again, of someone with a really bad leaky gut problem.
This is pretty bad.
You can go further into these and look at each one of these Syrex, this lab, who does this, has an individual panel on each of these individual paper at each of these products.
So, for instance, it's not on this, this is from Syrex 10.
Cord oleosin is a product that they, is a food product that they test for antibodies.
And it tells you it explains what this, what cord oleosin is.
It explains where it comes from, what's associated with, gives you some data, and some doughed cross reactions.
So there's no doughed cross reactions for this.
But on other things, there are doughed cross reactions like wheat and health of gliadins has a lot of different doughed cross reactions.
So if a person had only wheat and health of gliadins, positive other tests, then they may also, they want to stay away from that, but they may want to stay away from all these things too.
So this just gives you more detail on how to help a person heal that has major gut issues.
So it's a really good test to give a lot of data, the problem that people have with it is it's too much data.
And it can become extremely overwhelming, and I understand that, and I really need to make a whole presentation just the tests themselves and how to interpret that, because that might be more helpful.
But this just, we're just doing an overview here, but this gives you some information on how to start.
But really when you have a test with a lot of reds, you really have to concentrate on the gut healing protocol, more than just stayed away from foods.
There is another panel that Syrex has that's a newer panel. It's called the Bucosal Abutery activity screen.
It's a really nice panel that's becoming my favorite panel because it tests all these things.
So it's bypassing the food sensitivity, even though it does have some foods in here.
And it's jumping more to some of the other markers that would be positive for gut health.
And again, this is a kid that does a person need to do this test.
The answer is, no, a person doesn't need to do this test.
Personally, I have never done this test. I just assume because of my issues that I have gut damage.
And I need to be out of gut healing protocol. So these tests are not super cheap.
But they do give you valuable information that gives you some direction to go, especially if you can't quite put the figure on what the cause is.
What you do a Syrex array for like this one is or a rate 10, which has about seven pages like this.
It could be really nice, especially when there's just like one food or something that you would react to that you couldn't figure out what it was.
And this is very common with people that were like a good diet, a dairy free gluten free diet for some time.
And that we do a test like this and find out that they're reacted to tapioca starch.
And they're like, oh my gosh, that's it. All my gluten free products that I mean, no wonder it is.
No, I could put a figure out it. No, it brings back to their mind that that's why they have a reaction after they eat their gluten free bread that they eat.
So that's where this test really comes in handy.
But people that have, you know, cancer or serious disease is a necessary to do this test.
Not really. We're going to treat your gut anyhow.
But when you start to clear out the cancer and that's called down, then it's a good time to do tests like this to get more specific to your diet and to see if there's anything that you're eating that's causing inflammation that's hidden.
So that's just a brief overview of the gut tests and a brief overview of the benefits of beauty rate and why we have you on what we have you run.
So we got to keep that gut healthy because many of you are doing much better with your cancer and you're thinking about not wanting to get Alzheimer's disease or not wanting to get Parkinson's or, you know, any type of early dementia or something like that.
Well, it all starts in the gut. I'll tell you that we're going to put together a Alzheimer's protocol or a presentation here in the next couple of weeks that's going to be mainly on the gut.
So we're always keep holding this issue, but inflammation in the gut equals inflammation in the body and certainly inflammation of the brain.
But we're going to talk about that gut grade connection to that presentation.